today we're talking about some exciting
new game announcements and updates
including a big one for gotham knights
sony's march state of play is in the
books and with it came some new
announcements as well as some updates on
games that we already knew about the
announcement category features titles
like exo primal a new game from capcom
that puts you in a technologically
advanced mechanized battle suit so you
can handle fighting what seems like
thousands of extra dimensional dinosaurs
as they literally pour out of the sky
into human cities
others include valkyrie elysium deofield
or dial field chronicle and tmnt the
cowabunga collection
as for updates returnal is getting a new
survival mode and campaign co-op as part
of a free update
this is a feature that may convince me
to finally try out the game because i'll
finally have help for spoken was given a
new gameplay trailer despite the recent
delay from may to october and stranger
of paradise final fantasy origin is
getting a demo this demo's official
reveal follows a leak that suggested it
was on the way and now ps4 and ps5
players can grab the demo today and try
out the game before it's released on
march 18th however there was no word on
whether it will also arrive on xbox or
pc this demo will allow players to go
through the first three stages ending at
the western keep multiplayer is
supported and notably save data can be
carried over to the full game letting
you get a head start on the experience
to come unfortunately though there was
no new information about the sequel to
final fantasy 7 remake or final fantasy
16.
and sticking with final fantasy news to
celebrate the 35th anniversary of the
series a brand new website has been
launched which seems to be teasing
details about unannounced projects when
arriving on the website a piece of
anniversary artwork is front and center
featuring the warrior of light while the
iconic main theme song is played in the
background on the main page a message
simply states that the first final
fantasy title was released on december
18
1987 with 2022 making the 35th
anniversary of the series while also
teasing something new for fans the
message reads quote in this 35th
anniversary year we will be bringing you
many new exciting ways to enjoy the
worlds of final fantasy please look
forward to what final fantasy has in
store
switching gears to another exciting
announcement gotham knights developer
warner bros montreal has a new release
date for its upcoming action game
starring batman's vigilante family as
the game will now be released on october
25th of this year originally scheduled
to launch at the end of 2021 gotham
knights was delayed due to a need for
additional development time gotham
knights takes place in a world where
bruce wayne is very much dead leaving
gotham vulnerable to various criminal
gangs super villains and owl themed
secret societies that the dark knight
had once kept in check fortunately his
proteges nightwing batgirl robin and red
hood have stepped in to protect the city
and while that game was busy gaining a
release date advance wars was
unfortunately losing one advance wars
oneplus 2 rebootcamp which had been
scheduled to launch on the nintendo
switch in early april has been delayed
nintendo announced the news in a brief
tweet this morning attributing the move
to quote recent world events no doubt in
reference to russia's ongoing invasion
of ukraine
rebootcamp is a remake of the first two
advanced wars games for game boy advance
and it features the campaigns from both
along with the versus mode for playing
against ai or online
let us know in the comments what you're
hoping for in a future state of play and
what you hope comes of the 35th
anniversary year for final fantasy
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign